[Música]
hola muchísimas gracias por continuar en
la pantalla de france 24 bienvenidos a 5
minutos con esta oportunidad nos
acompañas amina gozaine ella es
directora general del servicio nacional
de migración de panamá
vamos a dialogar sobre los migrantes que
se quedaron varados en medio de la
pandemia de coronavirus pero nos
referimos a los migrantes que cruzan la
peligrosa selva del darién intentando
seguir su ruta hacia eeuu o hacia canadá
en busca de una mejor calidad de vida
gracias por acompañarnos señor agosto
hainer bueno panamá es un país de
tránsito no para estos migrantes que ha
pasado desde que comenzó el cierre de su
país el pasado 16 de marzo con los
migrantes haitianos cubanos asiáticos y
también africanos que están varados en
panamá
buenos dias santiago gracias por la
oportunidad mira estas personas están
ahora mismo en darién en albergues
provisionales y temporales vía que como
bien dices panamá es un área de tránsito
para estas personas y nunca se han
quedado tanto tiempo muy pocas personas
piden refugio en panamá por lo que
panamá no estaba preparado para lidiar
con la pandemia en ese sentido por lo
que tenemos 1800 migrantes en el área
del darín que han sido atendidos y han
sido cuidados por casi 6 meses le hemos
dado alimento les damos medicación les
damos atención a los niños tratamos de
darles albergues estamos ahora mismo en
medio de una licitación para construir
un albergue transitorio más adecuado
el viernes inauguramos albergue nuevo
para 550 personas para que tenga un poco
más cómodos entonces es panamá ha
tratado de alguna manera de
de responder con el limitado presupuesto
que tenemos dada la pandemia que hemos
tenido muchos gastos como estados y no
ingresos pero hemos tratado de estar a
la altura de nuestra responsabilidad
humana y de los derechos humanitarios de
estas personas precisamente hablando de
lo que están haciendo y de lo que pueden
hacer y eeuu recordemos que suspendió el
proceso de asilo en su frontera sur pero
los migrantes piden que los dejen
continuar su ruta y rechazan la
posibilidad de retornar a sus países de
origen que pueden hacer ustedes desde
panamá
nosotros estamos explorando con la uem
un programa de retorno voluntario de
aquellas personas que quieren retornar a
su país este retorno voluntario es
asistido por la óyeme tanto de haití
como la de panamá y costa rica también
que nos está brindando asistencia en el
cual ese programa permite que estas
personas retornen a su país y se les da
asistencia económica para poderse
insertar nuevamente en la economía del
país en donde están sin embargo como tú
bien dices estas personas más que
quieren continuar hacia el norte panamá
ha estado tratando conjuntamente con
costa rica de negociar con la región y
con los demás directores un corredor
humanitario que permita que ellos
continúen su viaje porque algunos
quieren llegar simplemente a médico
más que llegar un poquito más allá
entonces tienen familiares en otros
países de centroamérica y quieren
continuar su viaje que ya ha sido
dilatado por seis meses con estas
pandemias y cómo estás manejando la
crisis sanitaria en los campamentos de
la provincia del darién recordemos
frontera sur con colombia donde están
precisamente estos migrantes y también
cuéntenos qué ha pasado con los que
están en la zona limítrofe con costa
rica
si nosotros en darién tenemos un
campamento especialmente de salud donde
tenemos médicos panameños contratados
24/7 para atender a los migrantes
inclusive los demás campamentos tenemos
ambulancia y personal de la cruz roja
internacional y de la cruz roja de
panamá y conjuntamente con sinaproc que
le dan asistencia a los migrantes porque
hay muchas mujeres que estaban
embarazadas y muchas de ellas han dado a
luz aquí en panamá entonces nosotros le
damos atención médica gracias a dios
ahorita mismo en los campamentos no
existen ningún solo caso de kobe entre
los migrantes que están en los
campamentos así que estamos
constantemente preocupados por su salud
y tenemos asistencia 24/7 en el
campamento que tenemos en la provincia
de chiriquí que ya es limítrofe con
costa rica también tenemos atención
médica para ellos les damos atención los
llevamos si es necesario un hospital más
grande pero estamos atendiendo los 24/7
dentro de las posibilidades que tenemos
para atender a toda la población
la república de panamá también hemos
destinado esfuerzos para poder atender
los años se ha mirado cn muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24
gracias por favor a nuestra audiencia le
decimos como siempre que continúen con
sus cuidados sigan informando se en el
resto de nuestra programación y también
en france24 punto com
[Música]